tell them to send it to shakira
wait you're shakira
that's shakira hilariously reacting to a
viral impression of her ordering pizza i
want the pizza and i want to deliver
yeah okay then what toppings
the 44 year old singer took to social
media to share a duet with 21 year old
tick tock star shuba who impersonated
the singer's iconic voice while ordering
a pizza
that is a super choice would you like
any signs
the colombian-born superstar took on the
role of the pizza place employee and
took shuba's order in true shakira
fashion sherry butter pies are smaller
and humble so you don't confuse them
with mountains the accuracy of the
impression had shakira shook as she
laughed through the bit
i need your address now
the pair couldn't keep it together at
the end when the actual pizza employee
thought he was talking to the real
shakira
shakira jokingly captioned the video
hello shuba can i take your order please
shuba totally fangirled over the post
sharing the video to her instagram story
writing someone tell me this isn't a
dream
if you follow shakira on tick-tock you
know the fun never ends there's tons of
dancing
some
[Music]
surfing and we don't even know what's
really going on here but we freaking
love it
[Music]